[Music]
wake up are you late again
sometimes we wish we never had to deal
with this morning struggle but what if
you just never went to bed what if you
figured out how to keep yourself awake
forever how long could this sleepless
forever last could you even be
productive without recharging every
night when would your friends start
telling you to get some rest and what
exactly would happen to your body this
is what if and here's what would happen
if you stopped sleeping how often have
you needed just a few more hours to
finish off a project get ready for a
date or enjoy your day off if you took
sleep out of your daily routine you'd
have all 24 hours of the day to do
everything you never had time for what's
a few yawns and some minor tiredness if
it meant you never had to waste any more
time lying in bed for no good reason
turns out there are plenty of good
reasons to sleep the average person
spends 1/3 of their life lying in bed
eyes shots snoring away sounds like a
waste of valuable time but not for your
body while you sleep your body releases
hormones and repairs tissues replacing
your old cells with new lights if you
worked out that day you need a good
sleep to let your muscles grow and your
fat burn so what happens if you don't
sleep not much at first after just 24
hours you'd feel completely fine in fact
you'd feel better than fine that's
because sleeplessness stimulates the
mesolimbic pathway in your brain this
pathway would release dopamine and you'd
feel happy and full of energy but don't
be fooled by all that happiness it's not
gonna last long
soon after reaching the 24 hour mark all
your reactions would slow down your
brain would start to forget what you
were doing outwardly you'd appear to be
drunk wait where were we
right now what about two days of that
sleep at that point your body would
start shutting down it would stop
metabolizing glucose properly leaving
you with no energy supply you'd start
looking very pale your eyes would turn
red and then more bad news your wrinkles
would become more visible on day three
that's when the real fun begins
hallucinations starved of REM sleep your
brain would bring all your dreams and
nightmares to life and around the
72-hour mark you'd start breaking down
your own protein your muscles so say
goodbye to all that muscle mass you've
worked so hard to build up your body
would keep using up all the energy
sources are confined glucose leftovers
your muscles fat tissue after about two
weeks your immune system would be so
weak you could die from the common flu
eventually three weeks after your last
sleep you'd probably die of a heart
attack if you've got a little extra
muscle or fat on your body you could
stay alive
just a bit longer but we don't recommend
anyone try this at home anyway so grab
yourself a pillow and take a siesta if
it seems like you're always tired make
sure you're getting the prescribed six
to eight hours of sleep per night
[Music]